Hi, I'm Hernan Liendo, one of the 13 Google Developer Experts for Cloud Platform. I've been a university
professor for 15 years.
I'm also the Co-founder of Zupcat. Zupcat is the company
where I spend most of my time and it has allowed me to design technologies to create
massive games. In this video and in the next ones, I'll tell you the key to run products
used by millions of people around the world
using Google Cloud Platform.
In ZupCat we have made ​​great strides
like producing high quality games
which are distributed around the world. We also have over 15 million installs, and we have partnerships
with large companies in Asia and North America. We have achieved all this with great effort,
but also with the infrastructure that
helps us in these massive requirements.
Some numbers that allow us to understand the amount of computing are the hundreds
of thousands of events we run daily, or the thousands of challenges in real time that our players
play. We accomplish this by the automatic scaling
that Google App Engine
provide us. This behavior
can be seen in the Instance Administration Console
of App Engine. Here we can see what instances are pinned when more players enter the game
and then are returned when the number of players drops. We accomplish this with a simple
configuration in this file using the "Auto-Scaling" directive.
Regarding the storage
we have more than 400 million
entities in about 500 GB. App Engine allows us
to check the logs to a constant time which is independent of the number of customers
who want to access at the same
time and the amount of records we have.
We achieve this by auto-scaling that works as follows. When
a table has many records, App Engine automatically clones it, and from that moment
it began to distribute the consultations  in a more equitable manner. A very successful product requires
this enormous amount of load,
but don't forget, we have to develop it
in a very short time, with low cost of development
and we require a high availability
for worldwide users. We accomplish this through a combination of products such as
Cloud Datastore to host data.
We also use Cloud Storage to host content
and databases as Cassandra or Redis on Compute Engine.
In the following
presentations I'm going to give much more details
about these products and also tell you
about the architecture used in our games, that is Open Source.
See you next time!